foreign
[Music]
thank you I'm like I'm a show Pony I
need my action
okay so welcome into the show today I
love to jump right in and when I tell
you that when I started this podcast I
had no idea what I was doing I still
don't really know what I'm doing but I
basically decided to do it because I was
like oh I just get to invite people that
I'm giant fans of whose talent I can't
comprehend whose work I'm Blown Away by
and I get to talk to them and ask some
questions for you know an hour and like
they'll just come
and enjoy by the way Spa Vibes and I can
stay here like it's not a problem you
will please God daily get out
especially with that we were just
talking about your incredible luxurious
bathroom where I was like I'm just gonna
go check how I look and the bathroom's
like no this is a rehab for your body
image issues bitch you will never see
yourself in here it's so Zen I had to go
inward I'm sorry that I uh do not have
mirrors in my house in most of the rooms
and the ones I do they're either
cartoonishly tiny like a little um like
uh like a slot to look into Anne Frank's
attic yeah or it's uh the big mirrors
have to be really obscured in some ways
so you can't actually see your
reflection I have to tell you that you
would change the entire planet if no one
could fixate on how they look even
before something like this I'm like I'm
gonna be on camera it's like what no but
what are you here for I mean I have a
conversation with you which I've been I
love this I do not want people to know
if they have food in their teeth I want
them to embarrass themselves I want to
be the only one that knows it's probably
jerky it's probably I and it's either
turkey jerky it's like real bad
whatever's here so many levels so this
is an absolute dream so I'm just gonna
blather for a second again so you can
get your bearings
um so you did this show called Buy sell
date sell by date sell by date I'm
dyslexic
um so that was for the I did that
foreign
you made a movie that is exploring uh
the ecosystem of sex work and trying to
figure out how to keep women in the sex
workspace safer um and I remember just
my experience in everyone was talking
about this show so there are in our
business like you'll hear once every
couple years
the people that impress you the most and
whose approval you want the most will
start talking about it we'll start like
Sarah Jessica Parker will just like go
to a show and everyone's like what
they'll be like a like a US Weekly
headliner just Jared headline and it's
like Meryl Streep goes to see Sarah
Jones Show at the Geffen and you're just
like or what what's that like it's not
even something that's been forced On You
by agents it's not you know like in our
business there'll be like uh they'll be
pushing people on like that you don't
know where they came from they're like
trust fund kids that some agents niece
and you're like why is this person in
every show all of a sudden you don't
know what's happening but then they'll
be like a Grassroots show that's the
real deal and then to seem cool like
you'll bring it up you know what I mean
you'll be like you'll be like I'm gonna
go to see Sarah Jones Show whatever the
guy have you seen it I've seen it seven
times it's the best thing ever and
that's like Steven Spielberg it's like
that's the only thing that matters I'm a
hat and you're like I gotta go see this
show and so I finally got tickets to go
see it and I'm like I'm a performer it's
very rare that I go to other comedy
shows because I'm either normally
performing or when I do I'm like okay
I'm gonna go see something else
someone who's not me someone that's not
me and as a stand-up like look I'm not
gonna lie we're
asshole we're so competitive it's not
even compa I think we're so embarrassed
to try Fair very true do you know what I
mean yes that and Impressions and
characters oh yeah that's yeah that's
tricky there's no wiggle room it's a
Minefield you can't wiggle there's no
wiggling it's genius
or you like call the police it's pretty
bad it's a crime against comedy do you
know what I'm saying I do oh but also
most people I think comedians we have
this idea that's like well you can pull
it off with like that them but like
we'll know the difference yeah we'll go
look close when I tell you your show how
many characters did you inhabit in that
show in the theater version the movie is
inspired by the play but the play had 19
19 characters I was engrossed and I
literally remember
being embarrassed that I
I was kind of like I got played like I
just became an audience member like I
don't I'm an audience member I'm a
comedian like I didn't just fall for
that like I was like very high praise I
know because I know exactly what you're
talking about and I sit there and like
I'm like I'm watching the sausage get
made here I'm not gonna enjoy this shit
who the hell is this broad blah blah
blah and then all of a sudden you're
like wait I'm an audience member
professional tricksters got tricked like
me and Meryl Streep were like wait a
second she was all those like Meryl
Streep was is impressed she executive
produces this movie Meryl Streep
couldn't understand what was she was
like wait that's the same person so you
have This ferocious talent and to
inhabit all these different characters
that feel so specific you're so
committed I just want to ask you really
quick like how do you know
when you're in the pocket like because
it's all about committing to it like how
do you know it's
um oh my God does that make sense yes of
course it makes sense everything get out
of my head geez this is the thing okay
so I'm gonna be weird because that's my
brand please and by the way the if you
have not seen the three TED Talks she
has done it will blow your mind uh and
even I'm just so excited to see this up
close but anyway swagging my tail it's
like I'm having a little like yeah I
feel like I feel like we're the puppies
in the I'm just like because by the way
you've seen the TED Talks you've seen
the movie and you go oh well they did
that in post and they did she's just
doing this here I believe of all the
characters I identify with most deeply
it is Lorraine Lorraine she's bit and I
really do come from this mixed race
family and on my mom's my mom is in the
movie and you know I wanted to unpack
basically this is free therapy for me I
know you know what I'm saying and I have
no choice but to commit because
perfectionism is a you know it's a
terrorist in your mind that's like I
heard an accent that's kind of like this
but should have been like this and the
truth is these people lend this stories
to me whether they know it or not I try
to change their names to protect the
innocent and especially the guilty but
this is tricky because okay well we're
in different places in life because I'm
keeping nobody's Secrets anymore so just
I'm still people are still alive small
family members couple family members
maybe right um but uh so okay I know I'm
being a nerd because I I don't I don't
think people understand so being able to
mimic someone's Voice or build a
character it is like like you know
Michael Phelps is this great uh swimmer
yes of course he had all this privilege
and he had a pool growing up and all
that kind of stuff but he has his body
is is designed in a way that's an
anomaly basically he made the most of
the instrument he was given but he has
abnormally long arms right right it's a
deformity if he didn't swim we love you
Michael we'd ever he'd be an expert
shoplifter who knows what he'd be doing
with his talents if he couldn't get high
shelf reaching I think he has some kind
of lung thing I don't know who knows we
don't know uh Lance Armstrong has an
abnormally large heart I believe
um uh like there's there's right when
you Jimmy Fallon you you have some kind
of could you look this up Pat do you
have Wi-Fi you had helped me understand
my life because there's not you this is
a gift that you can you work on it can
you hone it yes this is the thing to me
for me and I don't know Jimmy Fallon so
I can't speak for him the but I've
talked to Merrill and you know other
people I admire about this who do this
kind of work John Leguizamo there's a
lot of people who like there's a tribe
of people who come from a multicultural
story it's weird when you're little and
you're sitting around the Thanksgiving
table and there's people there that's
you know they're from this place or that
place even now I can hear myself I've
been living in L.A too long so I'm not
really in the pocket like so you're
doing Chad Hanks right now right I don't
know who I'm doing I I could be doing
Chad Hanks on the side oh let's let's
back it on let's back it up and not get
anybody in trouble we don't want to tind
the conversation this is here here's
what we want but see I threw you too do
you know what I'm saying but I will
still stay there and I'll tell you why
all right let me give you this so so
like this so Bella is also in the film
um I you you are extraordinary I I don't
like I just feel and I was saying this
earlier that like white spleening into
spaces right now just like I feel like I
should just like be silent as like an
act of resistance but at the same time I
have something to say so like it's also
like being silent is like so Random it's
kind of random but it's also kind of
like I don't know I feel like silent
Randomness isn't it like random acts of
Silent no random acts of kindness that
is so meta it I am meta I wanted to
change my name my mom was not fully on
board and of course tuition has to get
paid so but as soon as we're through
that those woods um we'll look into that
but like basically like I know Sarah
Jones like that and again I don't want
to speak for like a black woman I would
never
um but like I know that she like has
like an experience where she like is the
person it's soups it's like soups
disorienting Even In This Moment Like
for me and I'm Bella know who I am but
like that's what it is so I think I mean
I guess what I'm trying to say is I have
I have spent so much time uh immersed in
other people which is a disorder as you
know like it's kind of like you know oh
codependency like literally the thing I
love to do is also a trauma shape shift
and Premiere other people and so this is
fat okay so look so much what you're I I
think I'm understanding is that like the
coping mechanism of being in the trauma
was which is what happened to me as well
which is in my case I'm not going to
speak for your primary character is mine
being alcoholics being people that were
Mercurial and very hard to predict what
their next mood is going to be one time
they're crying and then they're happy
and they're drunk but kids don't know
the difference and they don't like the
word eccentric we use words like
eccentric Jolly
narcissistically
sadistic you say convivial and Merry and
in celebratory
right synonyms or synonyms but um but we
I did develop the skill of being able to
essentially shape shift and mirror so
entertain when I'm six years old I could
have talked to a 45 year old I could
have talked to a two-year-old I could
have talked you know what I mean I also
knew how to mix a drink apparently a
pretty good uh two-finger vodka that
sounds horrible I mean let's do that
let's just all back it apart
like I and I say this with love I think
term dysfunctional family is redundant I
have not met these families where
there's absolutely nothing right and
even in the film like my goal was to
unpack some of my own shit yeah that I
have been tariff I've been busy in the
mirrors that are about like do you have
stuff in your teeth and you're here
saying fuck whether you have stuff like
it you know what I mean I want the if
you're thinking about what's in my teeth
we're not we're not having a
conversation but I'm also like so
embarrassed for you like I'm having so
much fun over here like I think that's
my main thing now I love that and I
here's the thing also I work in a
marketplace where there are people whose
only concern is whether you have
something in your teeth and so I'm
navigating this space and I think that
like you know the film itself and the
play the whole idea is like women sex
power you know power dynamics
um like how when I was growing up you
know I didn't know the Barbie doll is
based on the Lily doll which was a
prostitute in Germany like that's
fascinating to me that that like you
know the stuff that I thought of as
femininity and whatever is also kind of
bound up in like Commerce and how women
survive and make money and we call it I
guess I've been saying this but like you
know we call uh the sex industry which
the film you know that's where I go to
kind that's where the I wanted to write
something that touches on a topic that
basically the only thing I could think
of was like Pretty Woman No I was like
yeah when was the last time I saw a
feel-good movie that had anybody in this
world and in the original version she
died in the end
but they people loved her so much she
tested so highly they just kept her
alive they're like wait we never plan on
keeping a hook or a lot why would we do
that
and then though you look back it
probably was the wrong decision you look
at the CSI franchises you kill them and
it's even bigger SVU had she died at the
end the pretty woman would be the
biggest movie I mean the thigh high
boots would be but here's yes the point
being this is I may just I'm gonna do
this thing yes that's gonna seem
annoying and shitty and I and I'm really
working on not interrupting I have adds
no you I have it too and we are really
well met this is like the best game of
verbal foosball like it's just like oh
no no no no
excited but number two things happen
because I did realize it which is when
someone comes on your podcast I I don't
like when I go on podcast and then
they're just there and you're like I
have to do this whole show yes I also
should I feel the new let people know
I've done work I have questions I'm
gonna help but I'm also in this debate
because I feel uh very
um intent on saying this I'm gonna say a
two camera which is that this genius has
made the most incredible incisive don't
worry the cameras on me okay um don't
worry we won't do not worry we won't cut
to you in this moment
it's not it's real bad you know and and
my biggest pet peeve right now is that
uh you know so many great artists and
women finally have the platform to be
able to uh lift other women uh people up
that need uh light shined on their
circumstances and when they do uh the
very people that they're trying to help
oftentimes punish them micromanage them
criticize them misinterpret intent
intentionally misunderstand what they're
doing just to be offended uh so that
that is not most people I think that's
just most people on Twitter but I also
feel the need to just make sure you are
protected and I'm gonna I'm gonna take
the some of the bullets so um number one
uh the same way that that Barbie was
based on the whatever the German
prostitute whatever like you know boys
GI Joes were based on men that went to
battle men's bodies are objectified as
well they are sent to War for the most
part you know and uh you know women are
like why can't we go to work too you and
if women went to war from the beginning
we'd be going women got objectified at
War you know it's like there's I just
think it's important to always look at
many ways of it it doesn't mean we're
minimizing something else it just means
like for those of you that want to get
us on a formality I'm not gonna let it
happen no technicality I'm not gonna let
you get us on a technique I'm not gonna
let you bully us because you're
intentionally focusing on something
we're not even talking about that's
adjacent just in order well you didn't
bring this up yeah kind of thing I
really thank you for that here's what I
want this is my thing
I'm not here to speak for everyone yeah
I made one movie about my experience
yeah that's it I wasn't here to say I'm
an authority on this or that or I'm
taking a side or whatever I just want I
knew like I was like I don't think the
Pretty Woman I don't think Richard Gere
is where most of us not usually how this
story is going may I just ask you before
we talk about the back of the people
backlashing and being scared and all of
that of it because I have lots of
thoughts what why do you like at what
point in your career because I feel
similar I mean as soon as I started
doing stand-up I just talked about sex
and I'm talking about sex I don't talk
about porn and I'm talking about
prostitutes I'm talking about sex robots
and I have a sex
I think I know what what was your
yeah you know what's funny it sort of
predates my career so I was teaching I
started out like doing spoken word you
know I could like
um so many head wraps so much incense
it's probably still brain damage um but
like the that era of like I was
channeling my inner Erica Badu hi Erica
and what came for me was like I was able
to do these little like performances in
different places I went and started
teaching I did a poetry workshop for
girls I knew I was going to you know
underserved girls in New York that means
black and brown period
it turned out it was on Riker's Island
that there's a high school for girls on
Rikers Island so right then and there
we're you know we're departing from the
traditional narratives about what a
girl's life is supposed to look like
right and I was like this is something's
off here really really off that all of
those girls some of them 14 15 young and
I was like what are you doing here well
we get busted as adults and treat it as
adults okay this is I was like this is
draconia this is a uh like if you
explain this people would think it's a
dystopian sci-fi instead of going to
like me or something instead of being
taken care of as young girls who were
super fucking vulnerable and so usually
what happens is you're born into a super
vulnerable situation and because you're
a vulnerable you get into the life
really really early 12 13 right and you
were sexualized at a young age you're
sexualized at a young product you have
the first skill you have it's a free and
a lot of girls by the way you grow up in
New York you take the subway I was 12
years old riding the subway men
propositioned me all the time I was
about as tall and basically in this body
already when I was 12 13. so I think I
identified like okay girls and women
were sexualized early I get that but
like what are the what's the worst you
know kind of outcome of that is that
these girls didn't choose this
experience so in this Rikers Island they
were had been arrested for probably they
have been arrested for various things
including prostitution a lot of the time
right here's the thing we have laws in
this country that you can't consent to
anything if you're 14 15 years old how
are we vilifying you criminalizing you
calling you a whore and you're a child
any prostitution of 14 was right
anything prostitution you didn't consent
it's rape and by the way it's like
before 18. so here's my thing if we are
treating some girls and women like that
and then getting this other message on
the other side that's like sort of you
know like I said it's the it's the
Pretty Woman thing I was so confused by
that I wanted the like sexy fun you know
like reclaim my sexuality thing from a
childhood of like girls should keep
their knees together yeah I was like no
fuck you I want to be I should get to be
as sexy as anybody of any race because
that's the other thing is that black
girls are sexualized differently Latino
you know all of that and so it was this
complicated thing that I didn't even
know was percolating from the first time
I taught those girls heard their stories
of being solicited and then this is my
last real point the men go off to you
know back to lunch and they go to jail
I'm like what how are we like moralizing
that a guy who buys this young girl is
like a nice family man who should go
home to his wife and straighten up you
and then while she goes to jail 14. so
that I remember that planted a seed you
know it took a few years in Hollywood to
realize nobody else was gonna write this
thing but me and eventually I was like I
want to do something that people can
hopefully not want to Slit their wrists
at the end like I still want it to be a
compelling story I want people to have a
good time at the movies I want them to
be able to recommend it to their friends
how do you do that and I think the
answer is you have to Center those
stories but still remember it's not CIS
yeah it's not a CSI oh my God you do
what I did I do it I do what you did and
by the way pick up people's everything
your body shaped your already
the next time you see me and I have like
and I'm Flawless In Spite and like there
are horses all over my clothing you'll
know what happened I know you're in a
dramatic situation you're starting to
shave yourself but CIS I think it's
because I have being a CIS woman on my
mind right now but really like I'm not
trying to lock guys up for what you know
I just want to look at the world we're
in and tell the truth about it that I
think that's what this we call it cyst
women
because that's what we end up getting
all the dermatologists are going to be
so stoked if we can shift it to system I
was born a cyst woman I got this that's
a whole thing you want to be a woman
welcome you want me to assist woman it's
you this will happen for you we can
discuss yeah I had sex at 14 and no one
paid me which was very dramatic having
sex for free at 14. that's a real life I
mean they're both from what I understand
I haven't done either but I've had
enough of my own experiences to say it's
never this either or it's never this
binary thing right that's correct and I
think that what you do with your
characters and what you know the main
thing here and as we perceive this
conversation no two women are like no
two black women are like no two trans
women are like so when one person on
either side decides to speak for anybody
everyone freaks out but what people are
missing is that if no one talks about it
no one talks about it if we were sitting
around waiting for the perfect person to
say the perfect thing that you're gonna
like the Tweet of it's never gonna
happen so Twitter will be gone yeah so
to me it's like it's like Dave Chappelle
one of the you know best comedians who
ever lived like part of the reason I
think that there's so much you know
Flack on him is he's the only one
talking about steps into so I have a new
hour just talking on you know trans
stuff and drag stuff and whatever so
it's like it's there's one person
shouldn't be talking because everyone's
so afraid to talk about it so you're
just talking about it's like you know
and then people lose their minds but I
do think the onus isn't on us now moving
forward I don't want to give too much uh
oxygen to trolls because I think we're
also entering into a space where if
you're if you're where a lot of these
people are trauma survivors and and from
trauma surviving you get all sorts of uh
the inability to regulate your emotions
and if it's not hysterical it's you know
if it's hysterical it's historical and I
get it like it's like you know and I'm
not comparing women and dogs don't panic
I did that in my fourth special not
streaming on Netflix
um but uh that when it's like when you
rescue an animal and it's injured and no
matter how in much in your heart you
want to help it doesn't mean they're
going to receive your help the way
you're intending it so I think that when
you're in a space like this we just have
to acknowledge sometimes yeah the very
people that I'm trying to help them most
of the ones are gonna be the maddest at
me you know what's funny I have to say
this ultimately this film helped me I'm
the one I'm helping me bro I can't help
I I finally realized there's this great
expression in some one of my thousands
of healing modalities yeah I didn't
cause it I can't cure it I can't control
it so my job is to look here so as soon
as people came for me I was like oh they
don't understand I'm just trying to look
here I'm not coming for you sis I'm not
coming for you can you tell me what that
looked like because I I don't it angers
me deeply that you had to even comment
on it and I'm just curious because
um as someone that no one ever comes
after publicly as someone that's
universally beloved and has never made a
mistake like Twitter just like loves me
loves you and um so but for me it's like
that is the mosh pit people only go
there to fight you know most people that
will watch and enjoy this movie will not
even go on Twitter about they will watch
it they will enjoy it they will
recommend it to their friends it will
change their life they will send it to
their nieces and nephews and their
friends that have trans and then that's
it right it's it's a it's a there can be
an echo chamber Silo thing yes but I
will say this everyone on there is doing
the best they can with what they have
I'm not trying to be air I'm not trying
to be pollyanna-ish about it I know no
one intended to hurt me when they came
after all my funding and tried to cancel
me and destroy you know what but I know
can I can I be a Karen for a second and
disagree with a black woman
call the manager I got the trolls I I
think that yes you're doing the I like
you're doing the best you can with the
tools tools you have I I use that a lot
for my like parents and older people
like once they've aged out of being able
to like do the right thing that we
forgive you okay you still say Oriental
you're not you're doing the best you can
with the tools you have Grandma like
yeah get out of my head
it's you can't say or like you have to
call the hotel the Mandarin Asian
my daughter told me not all Asians are
the same Grandma listen We're Not Gonna
we are not doing age we we are in here's
the thing I can hear my Asian friends
being like Sarah back away
from the conversation hate totally even
though my job is to say stop Asian hate
and then to pass the mic to my Asian
family friends people that's how I'm
looking at this even the movie great of
course of course and that but but it
drives me nuts that you are already
doing so much and now you have to I have
to do more and I'm not doing enough it's
like this is why people give up yes this
is why people give up because it's like
it's nothing's ever enough and it's like
it's gonna be imperfect but I guess my
point is when people on Twitter it's
like you're doing the best you can the
tools you have maybe they're not because
you have twins don't blame me you're
just like you're you're on Twitter you
have the internet you see all the other
people getting treated like that on
Twitter you see when someone gets it
wrong and then you go this is wrong so I
don't know I think that a lot of those
people are self-righteous indignation
addicts and we are it's a drug I mean it
is it is you get adrenaline it turns
into dopamine and there are certain
people that it's not their fault because
you were wired to get some sick sadistic
satisfaction over someone else failing
or there's so little to celebrate in
this area yeah unfortunately what you're
trying to amend there's so much pain
there's a lot of pain that it's
impossible to even when there is a
sliver of light there's you can't even
appreciate it you can't let's carve up
the light and decide where it you know
yeah or our trauma response of what we
came from is so self-deperational and
we're so stuck in a cycle of an absence
of solution that we are going to stay
stuck with not even accepting the
tiniest little solution even if it's not
the perfect one and the people that you
know it's like it just it it it made me
very angry but this listen so you I feel
very protected but you are going into a
space of a lot of people and it is their
trauma what I will say is that's their
trauma response not their inner child
well here's what happens
take this offline and talk about
internal family systems and the loving
parent re-parenting yourself and all
that shit because I know you speak it
all fluently and it's like the best it's
like delicious but what I'm trying what
I'm trying to get at for myself
is everyone has trauma yeah the day you
came through your mom's womb was it or
cesarean also traumatizing literally we
walk around in our culture not aware I
didn't know I wanted to strip in college
I was like Yay and I look back and I'm
like oh my God so I can dramatized I
would have been but that doesn't mean I
get to say to anybody else this is just
me yeah I don't get to say Hey you have
trauma because I know I do and so I'm
sure you do yeah yeah all I can do is
listen and that and that so and protect
myself as much as I can all the time but
you can do that I can't do that I I let
you do that for me yeah because here's
the thing even if I see them yeah being
traumatized I know who I I was like I
would have told you like no no I'm just
type in like I just run my own one
person show and I don't know like this
it's like this because I was like like
you're telling but when people are like
because I'm a trauma Survivor like
that's why I'm helping you don't tell me
I have trauma you're like
I'm confused
can we start over Pat we need action
help us no it's really that's what I'm
saying I get it I get it what I don't
like is and it's not and it's not the
victim blaming of it right it's gonna
sound like it here's the thing about me
just just give me a second the opinions
of Whitney yes and Sarah Jones does not
take any responsibility Sarah Jones sent
from her publicist for me to read
verbatim um
when you have been silenced you want to
silence other people yes correct
sometimes her people hurt people most
pedophiles were molested I don't I'm not
happy about this right and you didn't
make that up and that's not your fault
when someone is coming to you being like
I've been silenced I've been censored
and I've been abused shut the fuck up
pull your movie you're like right I know
it is you do not see the irony here yeah
it wasn't fun I'm not gonna lie I'm not
I'm not saying that any of this was you
know my goal yeah but what really moved
me was oh my God as a Planet
collectively there is so much pain so
much trauma so much misallocation of
blame and focus on blame and who can we
shame and I get it I get it all because
I you know they're another fun
expression you spot it you got it yeah I
was at chick on campus who was like
um I don't really like like are you
wearing lipstick that's not feminine
like I just was I took it all on because
I was trying to be as perfect as
possible because you know I had a fucked
up childhood so what I try to remind
myself is everybody's walking around
with who God knows what diagnosable we
don't even know but all I can do is make
the best movie I can from the healthiest
place I can find on this particular
moment as a director or writer or
whatever and I did learn a lot I learned
a lot from people who I was like whoa
that sounds like Gale Winds of trauma
coming toward me but you know what I had
no idea that you had this with you know
like I really did have to sit and
suspend everything I think I know a lot
of the time to make this movie here's
the thing everybody's not gonna get it
everybody's not gonna love it they're
what you know I lost dear friends over
this I it was rough may I ask I mean
what I would say is I didn't lose like I
just am I curious because so many
artists and listen to like how hard you
were working on it yeah the topic all of
it sometimes you outgrow people because
you learn things and you're like oh this
doesn't serve me anymore everything I
like disappear I mean I if you go but by
the way the way to find the movie is to
go find me on the socials uh but I
Telltale it'll be it'll be there but
like it's yes I'm Sarah Jones across all
of the things I didn't have the
bandwidth to both make this movie and
maintain the people I love I was a
hermit like I did and I I have that
tendency I'm a what am I am an
introverted extrovert ambervert oh I'm
just a professional also that but like
it's real this is a the ways that we all
have the expectation that we should show
up you know well in this we were just
talking about like I don't even know how
to hug you when I see I'm like The Masks
look like this is all so nuts and you
layer it on top of this is a movie you
know they say what that it's the oldest
profession I think it is the oldest
conversation that we are not having in
an honest way about love and sex and how
connected we all are to this topic I
mean I said Barbie but it's like
families that are like let's go to
Hooters get some wings it's like hey
let's go you know the tits and ass well
it's selling of it is like a huge part
of this culture they pretend it isn't
and I think that um I want to come back
to something else that I forgot I wrote
it I wrote it down uh also I think that
when I look at this last couple years of
this like Reckoning and all the men I
say something to get me trouble Chalker
um but this is we have to with that I
said play the disclaimer again
which is this when I look at these men
that are dating the 22 year old intern
at their office I'm like there's no
other women
in the city
also you don't want them though I'm just
saying I don't want that dude but please
let the 20 year old suffer because I'm
not gonna my weekend totally got
everybody loses yeah I know you're gonna
go with the 20 year old I know she is
like a riveting stories
um from her life to traveling around the
world I know she's just like she knows
she can talk James Joyce with you it's
really good but I'm saying like uh the
solution to me is always hire a sex
worker for men many times unless they're
going to like a Ted Bundy person that
just wants to hurt someone and that is
sadistic and sick we're not talking
about that right um enough about my uh
phone book list I was getting my phone
yeah
um uh which is like to me the solution
will be so obvious I'm like yeah support
sex workers like just have just go if
you need to if you just got went through
a breakup and this is a normal urge if
you because because men hot take
to defend men real quick guys buckle up
we love you men have his biological need
and we're saying you can't watch porn
because it's toxic you can't cheat
you can't have sex with a woman too much
because she's out busy now women have
the online they're never home and
they're never around so but you also
cared your God like what what are where
is the cum supposed to go
you know what's so funny about what is
the plan for all this come this is this
is It's amazing I oh my God I don't even
know how much come is I feel like
there's a climate change conversation
that's gonna like meld with this at some
point
but we do also walk around like as soon
as we're able to and I know compassion
is not necessarily the word but just
have acceptance about like guys
sometimes guys have to jerk off once a
day let's just say that's a biological
urge that served them very well that in
all of us very well thousands and
thousands of years ago when they had to
I know a lot of women who need to jerk
it a couple sure they're great great
great non-binary folks just great
fantastic I just mean like if it's
something that has to if you can be
abstemious and if you have proof that uh
abstaining from sex is healthy or great
send me the info love to talk about that
great but let's say you know you don't
want them to have sex robots I did a
whole thing about sex robots and how I
think that would be a great outlet for
guys go for it you know flashlights
suppose you tell a good joke she tells
good she's a yeah which is why no one
will fuck her
um she tells your jokes that's what she
stopped being a sex robot so I'm just
like this it feels like such an obvious
um solution you know so my brain is
always like what either what's in the
way or what do the people that uh stand
to gain to keep this problem from being
solved two things one the annoying thing
about porn and men and all that like it
actually this you know studies show that
they get depressed they get anxiety like
forget about the woman who doesn't want
to have to do Gonzo porn right yeah it
also made there's a great book um called
porn Nation yes yes yes so if you guys
are into that I would watch porn Nation
I mean that's like that's a a problem
that I mean Gail dines has an incredible
talk about it uh yes what porn is doing
in terms of desensitizing but also it
makes sex feel worse for the guy so that
you're just doing that to yourself but
it's not our job to make sense
orgasms aren't as good for men when they
watch porn we have to solve this yeah I
know let's have a round table yeah
that's not you guys this is not my
circle jerk around yeah yeah yeah
um I think we yes we want to avoid that
but this is the interesting thing too
because this is these questions are real
right I I've dated guys who had like a
porn issue or whatever like for sure and
you know they're they're when they're
little boys and the message gets planted
in them somehow you're not enough you're
not good you know whatever they have
like right we're all human beings on a
planet where let's face it there's not a
lot of like it's kind of like you know
you suck uh make sure you make enough
money uh you know what I mean there's a
lot of messages of you're not enough my
concern is that if we don't address that
at the root yeah even trying to find a
solution like pair every dude who needs
to you know take care of himself with a
worker I don't feel like we're getting
to the macro level which is like there
are huge systems in place yeah they need
to be fucking dealt with like dudes need
to love themselves like yeah I want I'm
not married anymore or yet again not not
saying I know everybody's how to take
everybody's temperature but dude after
dude who I meet and I love them you get
underneath and there's a lot of deep
insecurity under there that nobody lets
them deal with and that is problematic
because when you mix that with they also
make more money than us still all the
time right like 72 cents on the dollar
is still what women and then you add you
know being latinx or black or Latino or
Asian or whatever else and it gets all
fucked up if you combine the economic
issues the racial issues all the stuff
we've been protesting right we all were
in the streets around George Floyd we
all understand that the worth of human
life and value in all of that is a big
deep conversation that's messy and that
needs to be honestly addressed and yet
with this one topic we kind of look away
from the reality that I'm sorry but most
of the girls and women who get into this
extra trade when they're vulnerable and
younger and not choosing at all and then
the complicated questions of like is it
about our choices or is it about systems
and there are so many women I've met who
are whether they're Doms actually you
had such a great episode talking to
Margaret Cho about things oh right yeah
she's the best the best but like the
point is I want a world like I want
everybody to be able to exchange sex for
what it's worth when we're in a world
where there's like a playing field where
those women get to fucking keep their
money so that I'm interested can we go
back to can I just yes because this is
my brain and why I haven't been married
even one time
um which is when because
my don't worry
um what my uh brain does there is goes
uh uh well okay we need to make men feel
better about themselves or like give men
the opportunity yeah sorry I ain't doing
it I'm not gonna say it that way I'm
gonna give create Faith so men can feel
better about themselves whatever and
then we also need to be able to so that
they can go do s m but don't you go do
those kinky things because something
went wrong well if men get healthy are
all the sex workers going to be
completely out of business well no
because here's my dream we live in a
world in which there is a a healthy you
know access to housing freaking
Education Health Care like all this shit
that like women have to do survival sex
for too often yeah if they could take
care of that and then also choose to
have sex whenever they want with
whomever they want and get paid that's
an amazing sound so I think that you're
so this is where I'm just trying to
figure out uh so so if you're it's it's
very interesting to to hear this because
I think it's I sort of came in going oh
we're going to talk about how to make
sex work safer your bigger point is
let's figure out how to fix the world so
women that don't want to have to do this
out of desperation have to that's more
than like is it's I say it because it's
part of my personal story that I have a
loved one and you have to go watch the
movie if you want to learn about which
by the way I have if I may just say
really quick I have very many good
friends that do what I do for living at
various different levels that uh charge
for all kinds of things they have uh uh
uh well no female comedians have daddies
let's be honest um but you know this one
has one that she just he'll say send me
photo your foot and she'll just right
away she'll just send it and then venmo
200 bucks make it happen and then he
they've never even met but uh the
agreement is twice a week she'll demand
that he send her money like I need 50
bucks right now and he sends it you know
there's all iterate there's all there's
a whole as many versions of this as as
you can imagine as people I would do I
would charge for sex if someone would
pay me well also here's the thing that
sounds really good and I also like even
in the movie on my journey I'm kind of
like well what would I do I mean if I'm
willing to be exploited by Hollywood and
do like terrible roles or like whatever
else what's the difference and I think
there's a much bigger conversation
around what do we act who are we who the
fuck am I wow like when you and when you
drill down to that it becomes a question
not just of like what am I willing to do
or what do I enjoy doing we don't even
know yet like yes you enjoy someone
peeing on you let's unpack that maybe
you do I'm I'm not here to give you my
pee maybe I mean if you want five if
it's five billion dollar you know what I
mean it's like Commerce creates this
thing of like who are we and what do we
even really want what are our value
systems and what is kink and why and and
so much of this stuff is in the shadows
because it's in the shadows that's what
I'm saying if I may I know I've never
been peed on I never enjoyed me I did
tell an accident trip down to the truth
random we were the Mandarin Asian okay
in in Hong Kong and uh
you thought you lost money before
um uh and then uh oh yeah and uh we were
just like really driving something and I
was like I was like uh I was like I dare
you to pee on me and I was like but I
can't I can't do it I'm just my card is
on file so we went in the shower range
we could still went in the shower and I
was looking over it and he couldn't it's
hard to do it when on the spot like that
we should have Trump
truly no but I I like if I were to be on
someone I'm like can you turn the faucet
on like I need it like just don't look
at me don't look at me like I just it's
too it's a lot of performance pressure
and then he finally tried to start peek
on me and I laughed so I could not keep
a straight face now the orgasm is long
gone I recommend it to everyone it's
hilarious apparently it's sterile so
it's also like a treatment facial
treatment a good friend of mine drinks
your own pee this is just saying we're
learning a lot today is what I'm trying
to say healthy LCS but what you're
saying all these sort of like perverse
involved yeah and we love to moralize
and attack each other for whatever Kink
or fetish or whatever and what we're not
looking at is like oh my God you said
earlier like hurt people hurt people but
like Free People free people if you can
just get people to the place where we
put all that shit on the table and admit
okay it's really probably three people
is Bella's favorite store yeah well I
mean like now you're putting me on the
spot around anthropology actually in
like a branding partnership that I was
hoping for but fine just Whitney just
destroy my like economic opportunities
but like the truth is we are all in this
it's like a mishmash of insecurities the
need to pay our bills and take care of
ourselves we want to be sexual beings
and enjoy our fucking self-determining
juicy lives that we deserve in a world
that's like oh by the way Roe v Wade is
the thing of the pet like right we're
living in like this Margaret Atwood
fucking dystopian nightmare as women and
we're trying to unpack like sex and
sexuality and commerce and all of it
with race it is very you know there are
Native American women in the film who
are like hi
some Western shit that y'all Colonial
like genocidal motherfuckers brought
over here and we don't even have a word
in our language for for this is that was
a mind-blowing uh it actually is
we you watch Sarah like you're like in
the
Wilderness
I'm like I make things like if you're
what you're just like is this like where
are they it's dark I was like she had
Burning Man like she's just in the
middle like is there a Black Rock Desert
like and is talking to these women and
it's obviously like heartbreaking and
it's you know and yeah and she was like
yeah we don't have a word for sex work
and right and I'm not here to tell
anybody yeah what they can and cannot do
I'm here to ask yeah I'm here to learn I
think that's what it is it's really just
like starting an uncomfortable
conversation I think that I I like to
think I'm one of those people I go I
don't know what I believe I get new
information every day I change my mind
every day yes I learned something new
but I'm just gonna keep saying the
ignorance once I have or the maybe right
thoughts today but it might be wrong
tomorrow it's called being teachable or
I might say something wrong today that's
like right tomorrow that's what was
weird that was an accident like you know
yes or like I mean and I know this is
controversial but like Notions of right
and wrong and who's better and blah blah
like we really there's such a like
hierarchy of like must be perfect at all
it's what drives cancel culture it's
like if you're not perfect if you like
you know one false move and you're dead
everyone's terrified you know to get it
wrong to be wrong you don't want another
attack cancel culture actually though
clicks fucking dorks oh there's that I'm
a dork though we have an epidemic of
doors and it's taking down our great
artists
and what I'm saying is though come on
like going on Twitter and going
fuck this documentary yeah you don't
know I'm gonna write a think piece
that's a think pieces I wake up in the
morning like what can I write a think
piece about this morning but really it's
mainly because like I'm slightly
concerned that like my ass is getting
fat but then I also know that I'm not
supposed to care that my ass is getting
fat because I'm supposed to be potty
positive and I'm trying to be body
positive but then like also like I am
keto but then I'm not really keto
because I'm also sort of paleo like but
also sort of raw like it's just a lot
yeah you have to think peace um
everyone's just hoping you just stop
thinking all together yeah I maybe just
don't think till you're like 40. well I
mean and the thing is like I don't want
to live till then even though I know
that sounds ageist but like I just feel
that like don't worry there won't be any
water left it's all good
hey Grace what's that noise it feels
like a rattler
there's a snake in my boot
there's a snake in your DMs that's
absolutely true at least one so Grace
how's your tummy it's actually so much
better he's not gonna lie to you you're
really Grace has had some Grace is uh
look I got I forgot that when I was in
my mid-20s I spent most of the time in
fetal position in uh Carson Daly's
office bathroom oh wow yeah
that's a step down from your bathroom I
think agree yeah that we agree on at
least your bathroom like smells really
nice
agree it has really good soap
I feel like uh I had not I'm trying to
think when I discovered even the idea of
probiotics because I think when I first
discovered probiotic I was so excited
but they didn't work so I was like oh I
guess this is a scam because I didn't
they hadn't yet uh figured out
you know this is the bath then worked
out the Kinks how about that gotta go
back to the lab so now that they've gone
back to the lab okay there's actual ways
to get you pooping right rituals
symbiotic plus contains two of the
world's most studied strains with over
350 publications of human clinical
trials I've read all of them every
single one I'm gonna be in the next one
actually I have a new project coming up
you guys I'm gonna be in the next human
trial for ritual so Grace's strain is
coming up now
um yeah these are delayed release
capsules that are designed to help reach
the colon not the stomach don't get him
confused look at a chart an ideal place
for probiotics to survive and grow and
they're designed with moisture
controlled bottle technology to protect
probiotic strains a lot of them don't
like that's another thing is that that
like when it's exposed to light or
certain moisture even if it worked you
know so symbiotic keeps it as a stay
potent yeah that's the whole thing also
I just had to go on antibiotics so I
really leaned into the same biotic yeah
used to be when I went on antibiotics I
had a UT tight tie for a long time time
freak out the cranberry juice baby not
anymore because symbiotic plus and
virtual are here to celebrate not hide
your insides thank you guys there's no
more shame in your gut game that's why
ritual is offering Whitney's listeners
10 off during their first three months
visit ritual.com Whitney to start ritual
or add symbiotic plus to your
subscription today I've always had thin
hair me too you know fine fine ass just
full big rat tail ancestry and I've
always had fine hair and I've never put
together that my scalp should be part of
my hair care routine
say more about that because I'm learning
a lot right now there's nothing else to
say that's there's that's I just never
like put my scalp help nope I've never
put my scalp health
in my
um listings yeah yeah I forgot I forget
that your like scalp is still skin like
you want you like wash your face and you
take care of your skin but you I forget
that I think that my skin stops at the
top of my five head which is wild
because you can see more of my scalp
than you can my face at this point
because of my hair extensions so I just
ate this okay I started using oh
no that was me this morning wait okay so
I'm just gonna say am I allowed to say
this Chrissy Teigen uses this
this is my endorsement I've been
obsessed with this um brand for ages I
think Jamie Greenberg maybe sent me some
a couple years ago and I was so obsessed
with the packaging because it's so
beautiful and it's the only packaging
that I think looks pretty in the
bathrooms so I bought it and I was like
I don't even care if this works I was
like I just love the packaging so much
yeah and uh and I also love the fact
that it is like you know a lot of
shampoos and stuff you buy it and
there's not that much in there it's like
you absolutely it's oh scammy this lasts
me for I mean truly like months anyway
so I started using it it totally changed
my hair I did not even realize that I
had stopped wearing black just because
my scalp would flake off all over the
place yeah people already think I'm like
a cokehead so I was worried they'd think
my dandruff was cocaine whatever I wear
black again you guys great good news
because away thick and full supplements
are vegan One A Day supplement so I also
in addition to using these products I'm
showing you they've started making
supplements okay stepping up their game
zero flavor uh so you're not gonna be
burping up Wharf all day supports
thicker fuller healthier hair they
reduce the appearance of shedding and
support hair strength gone are the days
where you get to take a shower and then
look back at the drain and see a rat
king
yeah like is that theovan in my drain
grow all the way with ah ways scalp
serum which we need to get those flaky
boys gone and thick and full supplements
go to
t-h-e-o-u-a-i.com and use code Whitney
to get 15 off your entire purchase
that's 15 off your entire order at
t-h-e-o-u-a-i.com code Whitney Grace can
you get us back to the show please back
to the show let's go don't yell at me
back to the show but this is what I'm
saying we're all in this and so how the
hell are you supposed to have sex and
make money and like do do your life
which and survive like right there are
people who are survivors of this for
whom like for them like I said if you're
12 13 and you're living in the Bronx and
you know this is like how you like are
first brought into sexuality why aren't
we legislating for the majority of
people making sure we never criminalize
women for any fucking thing in this
entire Arena yeah and if you're a dude
who's out there like making 500 whatever
I said 500 million dollars a year but
the people who are making you that money
are walking away with 40. let's look at
that that's a fucking problem and also
it's a Bezos problem like that's yeah
the same thing you could say about
Amazon drivers but can you argue that
and I don't know the answer to this yeah
can you argue that a lot of the girls on
Instagram and Tick Tock and Snapchat
that are making we don't know the
metrics for that I'm making as much
money as I thought if you're Blac Chyna
I mean if you rub some Kardashians yeah
yeah but then that's a whole different
situation but unless you are Elite and I
actually got to sit down with one of the
most well paid brilliant sex workers
that I met during my travels and my
journey and she also was like look we
need she was like very clear about this
is a problem that women don't have more
power so whether whatever our opinions
are about who should be doing what with
whom the power issue is the same and I
keep telling people it's the same as can
I say something that that would be uh uh
if I'm listening I'm like oh worth
knowing the answer that yeah I think
some guys
uh would believe in their minds or would
say like what do you mean you have all
the power in the world I'm sorry I
laughed I know it came from like my
toenails but let's acknowledge it okay
let's let's make clear why yes because a
lot of times we're also worried about
being dumb that we pretend we're smart
and we kind of know the answer but we
kind of also don't so the idea of like
well you have you can make money with
your body whenever you want right men
can't charge for sex right like if you
know what would be very limited limit of
course of course but you guys can get
laid whenever you want and we have to
pay for it and fight and I think a lot
of men would I've learned a lot in the
the Deep dive 4chan message boards of
this sex robot Community good times and
and that was really educational for me
yeah because I you know I think there's
this we want to go like in cells it's
not helpful we have to figure out why
right where's the anger coming from
what's going on because people that feel
rejected and maligned maligning them and
rejecting them makes them more dangerous
and recoiled deeper into their beliefs
so how do I turn up the volume on
everything you're saying right now a lot
of men yes complain uh that we have all
the power women complain men complain
not only that but in order well if I
want to have sex with you I have to take
you on three dates that's all there's an
algorithm that's already say 300 400
that's I might as well go I have an
Applebee's punch card but it only it's
not we're not there yet just the low
sodium and then I'm getting gas and then
I'm buying a suit and then I'm getting
you flowers and then you still might not
have sex with me and I'm so there are
men that are financially struggling that
would like to have relationships I would
like to get those knees I want to pause
you there and when they like Angry yeah
and then that you well you won't fuck me
so here would do they want to have
relationships or do they want to have
sex that's why I tried to pause I think
they probably do they know that why
that is a great question I think if the
uh that's something they might figure
out dirt I don't think anyone would know
the first wait I know I don't think
anyone would know that I meant relish
I don't think yeah I think that most
people want that but then you have to go
up the sex is good then I can consider
that I don't know so here's where I this
is fascinating to me because I'm in it
myself I'm swiping on these dudes I was
shocked I was shocked because I went in
these chat rooms and these men were like
I just got a sex robot because I started
hating women because I'd spend money on
them and then they'd have self-respect
and not sleep with me and then they're
like I literally can't afford a
girlfriend right no okay and this is the
problem right it's almost like the
sentence you just said it's like we're
in 1901 and the kind of woman I would
want to marry right right I want to be
with a guy like me right now 100 so
again I feel like we're back in time
because like the 1900s first of all uh
Arizona just put a abortion thing on the
books it's like 1900 so that's adorable
but we're back in time in the sense of
like those things are connected right
yeah like people not knowing who they
are and knowing their their own personal
power and knowing that their this is
going to sound so woo-woo but that
they're fucking luck like if you believe
you are lovable already yeah it's a lot
harder to think that you have to buy a
woman for sex like here's what I'm
saying here's what I'm saying you won't
attract you won't be looking for the
girl who looks like like right we have
all that these men are like they're used
to looking at women through filter it's
just it's amazing yeah well we are not
designed to see this many women like our
none of them
but I see what you're in the terms of
because we have so been so conditioned
to define the value of a Man based on
what he earns and a woman based on what
she looks like it's one of the circle
jerk yeah that is it but that gets
interesting because that is American
like I know in Japan like you the man
comes home and gives the woman his check
yeah like it's different in every
culture so they're not getting married
as much anymore right like if you look
at what's actually happening all over
the planet there's a collective problem
of like we know ourselves less we love
ourselves less we buy more shit and
we're trying to buy each other but it's
unsustainable and we can see it in
everything about the planet we are not
connected yeah with who we actually are
how we actually feel what we want and
what we need and it sounds crazy because
we're more connected than ever that's
what's so fucking bananas about it and
then can I ask what would you say to
someone who uh is it me
as I'm watching this because watching
this is so you know like
um I found myself just wanting to know
someone like I was just so frustrated
because it is such a complicated problem
and hopefully people listen to this
thing go okay there's I mean it takes
this is what I'm gonna focus on this one
don't get high right before you watch
the movie yeah you'll get lost I found
myself being like aren't we in like such
good shape now that we have the internet
totally now sound bath like it was so
much good shit Prozac
um uh your ex is probably gonna take
fentanyl at some point in your lifetime
100
um no I was like in my brain I would go
oh the internet you would have thought
that that would have made things safer
for sex workers right and it hasn't and
it made it worse or made it right so
here's my belief and I'm not saying we
solve it overnight but if we have an
honest conversation about the base layer
of like people are insecure they're you
know they're insecure about their homes
their health their jobs their everything
people are raised to see themselves as a
bunch of stats instead of a human being
Within music worth and value if you
start people off there and then for the
rest of their lives like I said I went
into your bathroom and I was like oh my
God I can't check to see if I'm like
consumable by the human population that
watches weather like right like if I
think that my worth and value is nothing
unless I have the ABS the this that the
money to buy the blah blah blah I'm
starting from a deficit and I'm gonna
stay at a deficit it's just gonna get
worse I know people who try to fix their
problem or their issue by buying sex and
it makes it worse I know people who you
know if they are sex workers their goal
is to you know do as much as they can
and then get out before they're you know
they don't want to do it forever yeah I
want a world in which people are making
choices that you know there's a line in
the movie like is it a choice if it's
something you have to do to survive how
do you know what kinds of choices you're
making and when and why and like when we
get back to it we're all talking about
freaking I'm on Instagram every freaking
day talking about self-love and you know
love yourself you'll be like to the
point point where then sex is fulfilling
when you decide to explore the let's
just say 12-step lifestyle of emotional
recovery sobriety or whatever the idea
is that you are going to get your
internal needs met internally and you're
going to no longer look to external
things to meet internal needs you are
going to take responsibility for how you
feel about yourself and you're gonna
stop blaming everyone you're stop
playing magazines and this and this but
and you're going to uh figure out what
your part is in it and then we can start
blaming everybody else because then we
at least know
right but I know which part was mine
yeah that's still bad but we still got
to take that statue down but I'm not you
know I'm not coming at it from a place
of not even knowing my own shit and what
I'm bringing to the table that might be
toxic or that might be trauma or that
might be whatever and
the Crux of 12-step in a lot in many
ways is a triangle of sort of three
major tenets is that you cannot build
self-esteem unless you're engaging in
esteemable actions so self-esteem is
built by executing esteemable actions
helping other people with absolutely no
car scorecard we call it being of
service double liking brene Brown's post
does not fix your self-esteem it makes
her very rich I'm a big fan huge fan but
people are very confused and she talks
about it she says you have to get in the
arena you have to fail that's how you
build resilience like did you have you
have you even watched her talk or did
you just like her quote because it is
driving me nuts that the more people are
uh there's this toxic mental Wellness
thing where it has turned into this
self-obsession of people just talking
about mental health spiritual bypassing
yeah that and I'm talking about my this
and my anxiety when's the last time you
like
like helped your neighbor
buy some groceries for an older person
but like go door to door in your
neighborhood find out who needs a weekly
grocery delivery yeah I mean listen
you're singing my song and I feel like
we are in such a wild moment of like you
said it's so confusing because we're
more connected than ever right I know
where my the kid I went to kindergarten
with found me on freaking Instagram like
this is wild and yet we can be more kind
of self-alienated like I feel alienated
from myself sometimes even on social
I'll be like oh my god I've liked like
seven thousand things and but does
anyone care you know like that shit can
happen so it's kind of this like care
for yourself at the most basic level
like at least for me there's an inner
little kid in there who's like I don't
know if I wanna have sex with people and
I have to like care for that wounded
part of me that I don't even realize is
driving the bus half the time what I'm
gonna can I say something yeah just so
what she's saying is you have to listen
very carefully what you just said she
said uh the wounded part of me is
driving the bus and I'm scared and I'm
reacting everyone trolling you that is
their wounded child trolling you not
them it's not their adults you know and
I think that I've I've had it I don't
know why I'm so militant today about
this because I just I've had it with
like good people getting shit because
other people haven't gotten their shit
together like you do not get to take we
all have pain you don't get to just
sloppily throw your pain out on people
that are trying to spray or fix it you
know what I mean it's just like it's
unnecessary it's boring and we're gonna
she'll stop guess what well she'll stop
I was close you know what I'm saying we
don't she doesn't have to do this she
could be a stripper she said it herself
first yeah
um so so I think strip sorry couldn't
but so I think sometimes we have that
compassion for ourselves yes but not for
others yes when we act you know angry
and I can't believe you were late which
turns out I'm just hurt that you weren't
here earlier and I miss you but when
other people do it we're like we think
there's legitimacy to what they're
saying yeah and we assume that everybody
I think it's interesting because on one
hand we go well these people are doing
the best they can the tools they have
and these people are very sick but we're
still reacting to it yeah you know so
it's like it's on us also just in terms
of this self-esteem and self-care to go
the esteemable action I can take today
to build my self-esteem is to not
internalize with these people who are in
a lot of pain are they're egging my
house yeah right people used to knock
over mailboxes with shovels yeah like
we've always done wild that was trolling
we always did Wild shit to strangers
like we always were just like fuck
there's toilet paper involved yeah it
was why
a little maladjusted in high school like
when someone trolls me I assume it's
like a lawyer that went to Princeton
who's like hold on I can't make that
meeting right now I need to send money
I'm like why did I like that but if some
went on the street who was clearly
struggling walking around in socks said
it I'd be like oh that person's not well
I try to remind myself I have no idea
what's going on with these other people
I have like plenty of information about
my own life and how I might appear on
the outside to you know have this kind
of power or understanding or whatever
but I have my own shit and I love that I
think it's in The Four Agreements or
something like nothing anyone says to
you is really about you they're in their
own dream now their own dream can fuck
you up and take your funding away and
you know like I've I mean Hollywood is a
wild ride for me because I want to say
what I need to say black women have had
it too good for too long oh my God we've
had six whole months you guys and
apparently it's over so but I gotta say
this experience for me of like really
deeply understanding that sex and love
and like how those two things connect
and living in a capitalist world where
we're all trying to like if you have a
conversation with you know sex workers
in Europe it's a different conversation
because like what when my health care is
taken care of so I don't really worry
about that and then the other parts that
I tell to people is you know well I'm
sending my daughter to University and
I'm like oh my God they have all this
money like they're fine they have a
social safety net it's not perfect it's
still if you're an immigrant it's
different like the power dynamics can I
say one more thing about that also
what's fascinating sorry to point that
pennant you no also they're Dynamic with
sex is wildly different than ours so
someone's telling me they went to Sweden
and uh to start working there and took
this girl on a date and they'll have sex
like on the first date between the
appetizers and the main and then they'll
date absolutely it's like it wasn't like
it's not like we're we're going to suss
each other out and I'm gonna like hold
this over you and we're gonna like
because once we do this it's like no
that's out of the way now let's see if I
like you as a person and it varies of
course right it depends on who you talk
to most Swedish girls are horse
Swedish volleyball team shit that you
heard about in the 90s that's the other
thing busy people that have jokes to
tell and things that they have to go
well that's not all I mean you know what
I I'm not explaining if you don't get it
you don't get it again the opinions of
Whitney are just those of you yeah so
here's the thing
this is a mess it's complicated it's
it's but I think pretending that it
isn't spiritually bypassing trying to
you know sound bath our way out of all
this stuff that's not gonna work either
it's not working and I think my goal
with the movie was just to say hey this
is a conversation that we're not having
let's try it let's have it from an
honest place that's not attacking
everyone even though I do have some
white male friends who are like um could
you go a little easier on the white
dudes and I want to be like hey guess
what um you guys are just learning
because you're like really scared about
cancel culture and everything but like
the rest of us have been canceled since
the beginning of time like my mom
couldn't get a credit card without my
father signing for it that's called
blanket cancellation so anyway my point
being where this is a reckoning sort of
but it's really more like everybody's
wounded like you said hurt people hurt
people that's a real thing like if we
could just remember that and that
literally like there was a sex worker
you know adjacent to our president like
this is yeah and everybody else is part
of our culture yes and I also think that
like no one wins more from this
conversation than white guys Don't Panic
it's true you're gonna get it we're
trying we're still fixing your ass
you're gonna get sex workers that are
even like more evolved that have bad
Health Care taken care of hopefully
unionized but and I wanted you're not
going to get chlamydia when you cheat on
your wife you're gonna love this oh my
God let me be clear I am advocating for
women to have access to fucking decent
lives yeah and if that includes women
being able to exchange sex in ways that
give them the power give them the you
know Revenue can I say something else
about sex yeah just because
when I hear sex worker
um I think dick in a vagina like there
are other there's a whole range I'm
saying so when we say this it's like
it's just the kind of thing that's like
this also means like sending nudies and
sending you know it's the whole it's
it's stripped I mean again it's this
I've talked to so many women in our
industry they'll be like yeah before I
sold my first pilot I was a you know I
was a cocktail waitress and I had to
take my top off a couple times and I
wondered like whoa is this feminist
I mean huh so I used to get hired in
college I'd get 100 to just like go to
parties 100 just walk around like I
would like stand around go to parties
you have to talk to people like just
don't be too weird don't get too drunk
you know like whatever it's marketing
there's many versions of Words sex work
looks and it's a whole Continuum you
can't tell me that you know just because
you're walking down a Victoria's Secret
runway in that you know outfit and not
you know the streets of uh Hunts Point
in the Bronx sure that that's two
completely separate things you're both
we're selling sex and also we should
have the right yes to make decisions
about about our bodies and what we do
with them in a context where we are in
an uh hopefully on a Level Playing Field
so that we're not having to sell sex to
like disgusting old men that we don't
want to be with just because we have to
pick buy diapers for our daughter that
we can't tell them about because it
would ruin the fantasy we'll just steal
his diapers she's solving all the
problems oh God the other day
technicians just a fountain of solutions
this is how much I should not talk ever
the other day I was on the plane and I
was working on this whole new uh thing
because I'm obsessed with like these
problems that we can't solve because
they're just too awful to talk about and
you get by the time you start getting to
a solution you're so bummed
I quit do you know what I'm saying tell
the investors I'm leaving I'm walking
off set like I'm just working on this
joke you know I'm working on this whole
thing about you know all like because I
have so many trans girlfriends and and
no one's talking about trans people in
the comedy space that actually has lots
of trans girlfriends I'm waiting for
Trans Comics to just blow it Robin is
the funniest yeah it's already it's
already it's happening okay CIS women
just made it so you guys just chill the
fuck out you guys are gonna have to
girls sorry you're gonna have to get as
much stage time as we did before you get
you know what I'm saying you're not
gonna get put to the front of the line
they might put you to the front maybe
well then we're gonna share because
we're women and that's what we do and
you're women and that's what we do I'm
just I'm just you I'm just mopping up
behind Whitney right now but you will
eat shit on stage up there
because you haven't been doing it long
enough so that's where things get tricky
is when you know a a friend of mine is a
younger trans comic was uh was a writer
first and then started doing stand-up
and was like people don't like me
because I'm trans like you've only been
doing comedy for a year people don't
like you because you're not funny it's
just you're not funny yet you're not it
might be that we just don't know
transphobia is real also you're not
funny very real very real but my
favorite thing about transphobes is that
um they don't understand how gay they
sound transphobes that's fun it's like
you're still in the rainbow because
transphobes will be like wait a second
that guy cut off his dick
no man I loved his dick exactly where it
was it was
it was like you have to clown
you're ridiculous you're ridiculous like
I'm just putting out all the
Ridiculousness of like how when people
are like you know trans women they're
running in track meets uh I'm like do
you have money on the game really is
that important trans women they're
faster than women and they're gonna I'm
like well they also have a
disproportionately higher murder rate so
what they can't be that fast oh my God
which is my God I can't I think I just
levitated out of my own body for that
particular joke so just so everyone
knows I don't know what's happening but
it's all pro you know what I'm saying
it's all on your side but then we have
to you know make jokes within there but
the point I was trying to make was I
don't remember I'm writing all these
jokes about oh yeah there's a as a con
doing stand-up what you do is the
hardest thing in the world
okay it is the hardest thing in the
world you don't get to where you are
just by going through something
traumatic you also have to do all that
you have to get that on top of it you
know so but I think that when people in
um
comedy or whatever when we say that
people go okay okay as long as someone's
not getting something you don't deserve
just because they're this yeah that's
when everyone calms down right so that's
why it's a maritime it's the meritocracy
which by the way yes and comedy will
never be it has I mean It's tricky
because it's it's it's always been male
dominated it's I don't know if that's it
is what it is I got it's always been
male dominated it is stuff has always
been but a lot of things have been
female I mean veterinary medicine is
female dominated please no one make us
think about it that's fair okay that's
recent though no I mean my mom is an OB
GYN the OB gyns were all male until they
weren't much nothing yeah was female
dominance
yeah you know in a hole
that the comedy World should should be
more balanced but obviously veterinarian
I was thinking about the other plan
together no I'm good on I like that
in clogs yes I want her to have a
necklace with her bunny on it that's so
good okay I don't want some guy named
Chad no you know what I mean Chad with
the bunny I mean then I'm getting into
territory that's like I there's times I
don't want a straight guy doing
something like I don't I this maybe you
don't want to you know mail that the
same reason I don't want a straight male
flight stewardess I just don't you don't
you don't understand
hey you're like flight attendant like I
need a little like feminine energy on
this flight like I had this like strange
like hey chick I was just like Jesus I
think I'm sexist like I really want this
disdain female you can be sexist because
you don't have any power in the airline
industry to hire or yeah okay that's a
good point it's totally fine I I hear
you I it's we all have stuff like that
we have to think through just say it out
loud and then you're because then you'd
get to do like uh one time I remember I
was working a joke about this uh where I
saw I was on a plane because I live on
planes and uh a female flight attendant
um female pilot walked on yeah and I
went oh
wow and then I went no yeah you went
you're twice let's have a conversation
because she had to work twice as well
and is getting paid less and we know
it's like dedicated and she fucking got
through and got through that so it's
like it's like twice as safe it's not
the same thing so when a comic was like
oh no here comes a female comic he's
like no dude you're twice as good you
don't know but if I hadn't acknowledged
that thought you have to work through it
and just been like no I'm just the best
person ever I wouldn't have been going
to go where did that come from yes wait
a minute okay was that human nature was
that right ISM was that phobia did I
read that yes but you're willing to
first of all you're willing to ask
that's a whole lot of right most people
like I don't want to look in here oh
this is duh you gotta just go I'm
probably having
as a black woman of mixed race
experience right so I got all the people
percolating this is the thing for me I
see these biases like I'm not there's a
moth storytelling podcast thing that I
did years ago where I'm saying like and
I did this thing and I thought it was a
propheter and I'm it's the I'm like
spitting it like it's a epithetic you
know I'm like totally shitting on women
on prostituted women or women who call
themselves sex workers and I look back
and I'm like oh I didn't know I was
ignorant like I was so afraid and angry
that cops had stopped me while walking
in L.A and assumed I was a sex worker I
didn't have any Consciousness yet about
how you didn't realize that was a
compliment I didn't I didn't realize
people must pay they were like oh my God
this looks marketable as fuck how do we
get in on this I didn't know to but my
point is ignorance like the whole thing
of like don't call people out call them
in all of that's real I just think it's
really interesting like so much of this
is not biology at all like the thing
with swim you know trans women who swim
most of the shit that people believe
about they're stronger when you actually
look at the science and the data none of
it's real it's just people freaking
themselves out and similarly so this was
fascinating to me teachers in the U.S
mostly women uh historically and
probably still now doctors were mostly
men for a long time in Russia I remember
finding this out women were doctors men
were teachers and it was considered like
ew you don't want a woman teacher she's
not smart enough she can you don't want
a male doctor and you don't want a medic
something like that so my point and then
I remember I was in India so Russians
have more empathy than us cool I mean I
am here to tell you that I don't want to
give
important opinions for anything but
Sarah Jones was about to say that she
went to India because as you do and
she's in India and she's in very nice
high class Hotel this is very confusing
I know I'm confused too I'm lost but
she's in this high priced you know very
fancy hotel and the people who come in
to clean the rooms all men because there
it is a lead job and so even in that we
call literally a hotel made you never
think of men in this position in this
Society I have to stop talking like this
I make myself crazy so but it blew my
mind that I was like men can't do like
my I'm there on a feminist tour but my
mind was like men don't do this and it's
like no no this is socialization all
this shit is made up so we we don't have
to correct ourselves instantly and Trump
is our first female president I mean it
was like it was like the idea of like
just like women can't run for residents
untrustworthy vindictive like dramatic
narcissists exactly so we had her
um and she had Stormy Daniels so it all
worked out but the point is I just love
pointing when people are like this topic
doesn't touch my life I'm like bitch do
you live in America because your
president was hanging out with a very
powerful sex worker and that's important
to talk about may I say one other thing
yeah that um about the sex workers
within like just in terms terms of doing
some I didn't want to do too much
research on what happened in terms of
you know because it is so uh well
handled in your movie of you like it
just breaks like watching any I didn't
want to go online and see what people
were upset about because you're really
just watching people be in pain and it's
it has nothing to do with you tomorrow
it's going to be someone out you know
it's just pain
um and uh you made it it just means you
made it what do they say like watching
paint dry this is watching paint dry
it's boring totally not fun yeah but
it's you know had very real impact of it
you know yes and if someone's mad at me
and they start emailing my sponsors like
I have to you know I'm curious as a
business person it was terrible I had to
call like foundations and be like hi I'm
I'm still the trustworthy you know and
but I would like to talk to you about
that because I think there are a lot of
people that want to do good things but
they're afraid of stuff like that and
you you know not you shouldn't have had
to but you had to weather those Waters
overcome and then you just ended up
incorporating it which is what I like to
do when I'm like you know uh if
someone's got I'm just gonna read it and
go I probably did do that you know what
that was fair I shouldn't have said it
that way you know I can see why someone
you know like you own it's called
accountability and fucking growing like
that's right there's a photo where's the
photo me uh I I show it um a lot when I
was uh 20 I dressed as a geisha for
Halloween yeah and I was like I did this
yeah I did this yeah I didn't know I
didn't know I was ignorant I didn't know
I'm sorry and like and like truly I give
you know I make amends if you will and
like give what I need to get and if I
don't say that all the other people that
did it and didn't know they're gonna
okay it's fine I just don't do it again
I don't have to lean into my I don't
have to double down right don't do not
double down she didn't lose her job
she's still you know because when and
this is such a B in my Bonnet when the
girl that was hired to be the
editor-in-chief of Teen Vogue oh yeah
the first woman of color they had is the
editor of Teen Vogue unbelievable she
was the staff found tweets of that she
sent when she was 16. they fired her
yeah and I was like you know what before
she started I believe she's even more
qualified for the job now because you
want someone to run Teen Vogue that goes
I know what you shouldn't do right let's
talk about what the information I didn't
get right and holding yourself
accountable like that's my thing educate
me like I will admit all day I need to
learn no one wants to stay dumb no
please no one wants to if you if you
want that your goals are wow that's just
such a trash goal again Trump trash goal
is such a funny so so in in comedy being
female dominated you know yes and you've
been in the stand-up space a little bit
too but like within the stand-up space
I'm just gonna say it they're so they're
you know and not so much anymore when I
started there are so few of us the
scarcity complex was very intense and it
was me versus you yes you know it was
they need one more on the lineup they
need to check a box right and if they
ever get behind me bitches because
sometimes I think the same thing happens
with you know uh people in this space of
a forward-facing sex worker a
forward-facing trans person four-facing
black one it's like there's so few
people speaking and that it's like
um we don't always get along we don't
always agree on everything but there's
this thing that happens that's like okay
we have to have some like we've been
pitted against each other hate each
other because everyone benefits from us
not that's right sticking together
scarcity and we we fell for it and we're
still like you know I think we're
crawling out of it I I hope I like to
believe that we're crossing that we're
aware I think sometimes that's part of
it where it's just sort of like when
there's so few people that speak about
it when someone does the pressure's so
intense yeah that everyone freaks out of
like you know you only had 30 seconds on
the microphone to speak for so many
people that never get to speak right
just that everyone loses their you know
what I mean so I think it's just more
more um uh more time more more time more
spikes we need more we need to build our
own stages we need our own mics we need
to not be dep and I'm not saying we
don't want to incorporate like I'm
grateful for like I'm so glad you're on
Netflix I'm so glad I got to do a show
on Netflix but I I also know that there
are Gatekeepers who aren't wanting this
conversation because Free People free
people also means you don't you can't
control them as easily and I think
there's a sweet spot where like we can
actually collaborate stops having the
scarcity mindset that says there's only
room for one of us or whatever and it
actually if we drill down to like like I
said who am I how do I feel what do I
want what do I need and probably
everyone else around me like needs to
ask those questions we don't we're
mostly walking around like up armored
defended scared our inner wounded kid
like you said is running the show we're
asleep I've heard it called um the
trance of unworthiness that shit was
like because it's a feeling of like I'm
not good enough that's left over from
childhood but I promise you if you you
know like you were saying I used to get
I used to go to clubs and get paid to
walk around and like do the and it
teaches you this is my worth and value I
used to straighten my hair I had to like
maintain my body had to be a certain
like that shit is a prison and men have
it too and non-binary folks so the more
we're trying to like St you know the
more we feel like we have to please
Gatekeepers in order to survive like if
we have to Market ourselves to a world
that it's limiting us yeah we are going
to you know kind of tear each other down
I think what we need is kind of an op
the opposite approach of like both and
like you get to shine I'm gonna help you
shine now a word from our sponsor better
help uh we've been talking about therapy
on this podcast a little bit and
I guess it's like better help existing I
know you guys have heard of it I know
that it's like
it's very popular right now to talk
about going to therapy but not actually
going or saying you're gonna go every
single person was like yeah I'm in
therapy I'm like oh my God so like
that's so great how long have you been
going to therapy for and they're like
well I've been looking for a therapist
for like six months sure sure get on
better help you will get connected with
a therapist within 48 Hours you will
start having appointments with them like
you will be meeting them you'll be
texting them at all hours of the night
they'll be telling you to go away like
it is it's you'll immediately be
annoying a therapist instead of like
hounding receptionist to get back to you
but what I will say is when someone says
I'm in therapy I'm like I don't think
I'm in Fair like you don't have to make
that big of a commitment I feel like
people are like they think if they go to
one session they're in therapy right you
might need two sessions you might need
10 years so you might need just couples
you might need just to go there's times
that I have gone to a therapist that
I've never been to before just to get
like a fresh a fresh set of eyes on one
situation yeah do you know what I'm
saying I am so I am poly therapist I you
know sometimes I go three times in a
week and sometimes I won't go for a
month I've been I've been in therapy for
a long time in different ways but I
think that like you know better help
makes it so easy so that you know you
can switch a therapist if you need to if
it's not the right Vibe for whatever
reason you know or you can do whatever
you want you can cancel whenever you
want but you can get matched after just
you all you do is fill out a survey at
least you can start the process even
though not for you yep or even if it's
not the right person at least you're not
like oh I have to plan three months I
have to drive 49 miles and get nine
parking tickets this is so expensive go
to therapy from your home yep do it on
Zoom none of you go to work anymore
anyways just like slot it in the middle
of the day is this true or not but
there's word on the street that there's
a mental health crisis I haven't seen a
lot of proof but
you know it's because all the proof is
right here in this room it's true this
is the Pandora's box of the Mental
Health crisis when we open that door
it's Unleashed on the world
if by Mental Health crisis you mean
never had more fun in my life when you
want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can get you there honestly at
the end of the day it just makes your
life easier it makes your life better uh
you and people say oh it takes too much
time you save time when you go to
therapy because you stop wasting a bunch
of time in relationships you shouldn't
be and apologizing for things you didn't
do wrong visit betterhelp.com Whitney
today and get 10 off your first month
that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash
back to the show I so I must say for me
it's one o'clock Sarah Jones don't drink
but um anyway no we get it I'm white
it's not wine o'clock he's it's um it's
gummy a call
about to have a drink with Bella Rose
that would be Rose Bella get tie off
kombucha at this point it's fine oh
you're gonna say come I was like Wow and
we're
and we're conversation about purifying
the water okay what ages I do that we do
something
I'm not I know this sounds like I'm
being like where should the come go like
it needs Solutions I'm telling you
they're going to enjoy jerking off more
yeah when they like imagine porn might
be coming here's my thing I think
because and I went to an international
school when I was a kid so I met all
these European boys right around the
time that I was learning stuff and we
did not have porn on phones that was I'm
old enough that there was not the porn
on the phones but I remember that there
was enough of like basic self-con these
people like not all of them some of them
were shitheads but some of them were
like hey I like you you like me it's
like whatever and like let's have safe
sex and listen and it wasn't all fucked
up and Gonzo porn and whatever and
everybody just kind of I'm not saying it
was a Utopia there were problems but
there was a lot more of a sense of like
unforgivable like I'm not just gonna
like yeah you know give somebody a blow
job and then the next thing I know it's
texted to everyone in my school oh yeah
like I think the fear culture and the
kind of pain organic that we instill in
you know the youngest people that's what
we're watching kind of come to fruition
now and so if we can dial back the like
one false move you're dead if you're not
perfect you suck like if you make a
mistake you know you're you're not
redeemable yeah that's what I hope or we
get to work on and then
sock
don't leave it for somebody else to
clean up like learn to take her
to take a relationship yes and this is
I'm gonna say something I love this
topic because it's they're so many
um variables yes you know and so and
it's the best opportunity to talk about
all the uncomfortable things uh like for
uh we skipped over when we were talking
about the plain thing of when you're
like when you have Solutions I literally
genuinely thought this the other day I'm
like okay scared pedophiles okay so
pedophiles warm elasted yeah that's a
problem okay that's a problem because
it's just you know it's like and then
the shape the what you know drives
pedophiles is the shame so when you are
an alcoholic or drug addict a sexy you
can go to a meet you can go somewhere
and go hey I want to have sex with 900
people today and while my kids are at
school and people go
everybody claps you are so brave here is
a little chip thank you for sharing
you're a hero like thank you like I
appreciate you thank you for that you
like saved my life my day is better
everything
because of your bravery if you're a
pedophile and go hey I I just looked at
a kid and I think I want to have sex
with the kids yeah like you can't you
can't do that you can't do that there
are therapists I'm sure that I mean okay
this is I hear you I mean look I would
kill you I'm not saying I'd be any
better but this is where I have to go to
a meeting and be like I killed a man
this is right yeah and they're like this
is where my brain goes yeah I'm like you
know this technology is coming
snorted I snorted because there are a
lot of the people that are problems in
our society are high functioning
Psychopaths so a lot of the leaders the
deaths Associated Psychopaths they do
they just have an advantage let's shoot
right up the letter so but you now it's
it's it's because I work with these uh
uh people in abusive situations to help
them be able to take their dogs when
they leave because a lot of people don't
leave abusive situations because they
don't want to leave their animal and
it's protection for them women Etc and
so but you can and and we're working on
connecting a database that connects uh
children that kill animals uh to later
and crimes later because you know that
is oh my God 100 predictor you know what
to talk about so what if we connected
the pedophiles with the child
Psychopaths
I don't even know where to go with it
they could just get it out of their
system without us feeling bad
I don't know it sounds like a
multiplication and not a subtraction
yeah I'm feeling I'm feeling I know it's
less about math
I'm feeling
I'm feeling like everyone loses in this
scenario I see an opportunity
okay I don't know that I'm there with
you I want to Pivot to like do you know
that Norway has the most like Humane and
beautiful prison system in the world
gonna be focused on that
Norway because Norway is like Saudi
Arabia I mean the the part of the reason
I feel fine making fun of Saudi Arabia
is because Norway had the same situation
happen and they distributed all of the
wealth from the oil they found to
everyone free college you got a stipend
I when I performed in Norway Scandinavia
stuff with women is so it's another
planet it's another planet I'm old man
or like I'm a feminist of course I'm a
feminist which is a great way to get
close to you but they mean it because
they do get the people but I mean with
good reasons I would I have them down to
give it up to Swedish people if they're
you know I'm on the phone with uh uh
because this is what phones look like
still very much so um uh and it was like
some journalists and I'm like just on
autopilot you know what I mean you're on
the phone and you're just doing your
bits and doing here I love Norway
I'll come to Norway I'll come to the
strip clubs meet the girls and he goes
oh we actually don't have a strip club
here because uh it opened and you know
you know we don't have any and it's gone
now or something like that I was like oh
God is it like outlawed there or
something he goes no we open one and
then there were protests and they shut
it down I was like oh why what happened
and he just went oh over here we um we
respect women
performing in Stockholm when I tell you
every joke I was like bombing stuff that
kills in America bombing because I
bombed in Stockholm also well because I
was like you know when a guy like hangs
up on you they're like no no and then
there's like girls in the front row and
I was like single ladies and they're
like oh no we have husbands we're like
okay where are they they're like they
respect us a paternity leave yeah
they're at home with the babies that was
true they're okay
it was like why so there is a lot of
specific Americans and stuff here which
makes it a little less
um
it's not just human nature it's not just
humans no we're social we've fucked up
Social here's the thing America is
amazing in so many so many ways such
incredible history people's movements
it's the good shit the fact that we can
protest in the streets the fact we
didn't talk shit about our leaders I
mean as you said recently like the whole
thing with the Royals we're like we're
not fucking doing that we're not giving
you our money so you can steal diamonds
from other people and then like first go
to your job when you're like 97 because
you what did you you said the funniest
shit anyway the point being in some ways
we get it we get freedom and the right
to be who you are expression all of that
we get it deeply in other ways we still
have all the puritanical shit of like
you know raise yourself up by your
bootstraps that isn't true by the way
one of my favorite things is like the
illusion and I'm just gonna get I'm
gonna get real racial for a second and
like bring out Rasheed because he hasn't
real quick the point is that you know
I'm saying as the only dude Savage Jones
put in the in the um
um film and as a black dude um in
addition to that fact
um what I would like to bring up is like
America is full of myths y'all it's just
it's an amnesiac I don't even know if
there's a word but this shit y'all just
only hold on to shit you like and then
the shit that you don't like you be like
Oh I'm sorry I'm not familiar with that
you're gonna have to speak to my
representative well I can't hear you I'm
sorry you're breaking up so America
y'all don't even realize you know I was
like damn white people they got their
shit together they got you know what I'm
saying they just like hooked it all up
and we you know in hurricanes and shit
Katrina we just all fucked up I ain't
know y'all got some of the biggest
welfare that ever happened y'all the
land grants look that shit up look up
land grants and understand this whole
country all this shit about I'm free and
I you know what I'm saying I don't need
no handouts yeah all the swedes I know
we going back to Sweden but Sweden
Norway they had all these um Native
Americans and they were like yo we got
to get these Native Americans killed
right quick let's get us some nice white
Europeans to whiten this shit up real
quick cause we don't like these Eastern
Europeans and Jews and whatnot we don't
want that let's get some Europeans give
them some education and some money and
um give them all the land let them kill
all the Native Americans all right we'll
be right back that's America and so to
me this movie is just a corner of like
we have to stop lying about how we are
and the illusion of like rugged
individualism and White House is built
by slaves White House was built by
States and it's just a fact it's like
here to rub anybody's nose and anything
except it's like oh it rained I'm not
here to be like leftist like it's not
rain like yeah it just happened like it
just happened and like let's not make it
Thanksgiving just didn't it didn't
happen like that at all
it's really good I know that like
there's we learned all this stuff at
school it's probably a little stressful
to be like oh all that was wrong all
wrong it's totally I remember my dad I
think that's why I became a comedian
like my dad used to make me study study
study because he was like you're a woman
you're always having to work twice it's
hard to get half as far you're gonna get
a curveball a guy's gonna pull your hair
you're gonna visit and you're gonna need
to be able to do this in your sleep and
he would wake me up in the middle of the
night and ask me spelling drills yeah
and you made me memorize the entire book
backwards as far as back and forth and
he closed the uh book and he'd be like
shame none of that's true and I was
always like what and he was like nothing
never mind and I remember that was my
first question everything he'd always go
well this is a question this is just
some asshole like making it up and
making it biased right we don't hear
about women's history we don't hear
about Native history we don't hear the
truth so what I'm saying is let's all
tell the truth if we start gentle
everybody start waking up again because
I know 2020 happened and then we all hit
the snooze yeah you know broke a lot of
people
it broke all the alarm clocks we're all
like fuck like Beyond repair yeah it's
real bad but I don't think we're ever
Beyond repair I really don't I think
sort of like you know you take a kid I
work with young people a lot of the time
who are like if you take my phone away I
cannot make eye contact with like
anything or anyone take your phone away
for like two three days suddenly you
come back online like we are always
redeemable repairable like I'm not
saying reparations I am though
reparations motherfucker anyway um my
point being everything can be saved
everything can be fixed even at those
terrible states that we find ourselves
in now if we just start I believe that I
really do can I ask a question I'm just
gonna you're the funnest and we just
take a moment to say like I don't get to
do you're getting this out of me and now
you're saving my friends relatives I
love doing this and you're the only one
who will let me do it so far oh my God
right well there's no there's no um like
you can't you can't do like um
dimensionalize this compartment seven
minutes on a talk show like this is like
the pr I mean like I love I don't love
pot I love this podcasting is so hard
and confusing and I never know but
conversations like this I'm like this it
should exist oh my God whereas other
times I'd be like is this funny is this
interesting is this boring who the fuck
cares that I was in Cincinnati this
weekend why are you listening like I
can't I get resentful of the people that
actually but this is the point this is
what it's all about is like being able
to talk about we can be funny and
serious and wrong and right and you need
it all yeah I watch the Cincinnati but
I'm the pathetic I love it I like to do
let's do the let's have all the
conversations that you you can't have so
that you can and ask all the girls
questions that are you're too
embarrassing uh that are too
embarrassing to ask I will yeah exactly
I volunteers tribute so when we talk
about like male trauma which is just not
a popular topic uh but then you you know
say like men are insecure and they're
worried about their bodies too and men
don't get to be emotional and even
though pretty much every podcast now is
just men making million dollars talking
about their feelings
emotional creatures yeah
um it's just guys talking about their
depression I'm like cool brought to you
by athletic you got a million dollars
just to say your feelings are hurt like
okay cool I know it is kind of it must
be nice it's like wait we're back to 72
cents on a dollar again even with the
like depression pods 45 year old man
being like sometimes my feelings could
hurt people like
um so I don't think that we you know
take male trauma very seriously I I do
joke about this but it is amazing that
when men get molested nobody cares and I
mean literally nobody Matthew
McConaughey just on um Amanda Academy's
podcast I mean this is where shit really
breaks is where we're taught actually
able to talk about I mean I did not
think of Matthew McConaughey I was busy
being like I think it's like whatever I
had my opinions oh did he have sexual
Obama yes he and he shared about it on
this pod that like I don't think it
really imagine if I mean this is my
mother's whatever generation but I
remember the term John Wayne was like a
an adjective John Wayne is this actor
this Cowboy yeah yeah and he was sort of
like reveal he's like the definition of
American manhood for like the
generations before Roman Marlboro Man
like shoot you know shoots native people
on site and you cheer like this is what
people grew up with so I'm just saying
this doesn't come out of a vacuum like
you have to undo this shit and it is
important like I think we should still
pay like you know like let's not just
overpay for white men's pain but I do
think it's like if we don't talk about
how we got here and like you said sexual
trauma this is all part like there's
lots of people who don't say it until
their deathbed but we like think it's
like funny like God right we do make
videos like we Insanity cannot be
restored or on any in any capacity but
number one uh it's not intersectional so
I went to my second uh women's March
this was whatever it was for whenever
all that happened and I remember I'm at
the marsh I'm there and I'm like call a
girlfriend I'm looking around like I
don't see any black women yeah yeah
before everyone was just in pink and
pussy hats I wasn't thinking about it
the next one I call A girlfriend of mine
I was like hey are you coming and she's
like yeah no you why women are the why
this is all happening and I was like got
it okay right so then we adjust yeah we
learn and then just to be like okay when
the women in Hollywood when someone hugs
them too long we all shut down
uh but when a man gets molested by a
priest at five like no one gives like
literally no one cares we like make
jokes about it we just think it's fine
myself have made lots of jokes about it
like not as a way to minimize it the
joke's about like if you are a boy that
is molested in the Catholic Church like
there's no charity there's no marches
the only solution is really a a and
that's in the basement of an abandoned
church like which which really helps
with right no one cares like it's no one
gives a shit no one talks about it like
so there's that and then there's also I
was reading a long time ago and what I'm
getting to is I'm too afraid to bring
this up yeah um because I I definitely
don't know enough about it but people
that do know a lot about it have written
about it and I'm too afraid of seeming
insensitive to someone else's culture
when I bring it up which is about how
much circumcising boys traumatizes them
uh there's like all these studies about
I feel like I can't bring it up I know
40 Jewish right I've all the men in my
family ten percent okay yeah so I have I
have less of a so so I'm not coming for
Judy it's not only done right for Jewish
there's other cultures that do it for
other religious reasons and I don't want
to say but there was a uh uh this study
about it where
um it it because the baby is bonding to
the mother and is associating that like
you did this to me in trauma yes exactly
you know and it's something that a lot
of people don't talk about I don't know
why people don't want to talk more about
baby dicks but
um because I I feel like this thing I
think it's a hard field to go into
really it's it's a treasure it's a
little bit it's a treacherous past it's
a treacherous It Feels Like A Catch a
Predator in type a little bit that
medical if you really do expect that
dude baby circumcision and the jail is
this way so but there is we gotcha there
was like there's a lot of studies going
on about just that like that alone
babies in general when we change diapers
for babies and we go the couple right
yeah yeah oh shit you're setting up
therapy for that kid they're going this
is bad right I'm bad all those little
things and it's so tiny Whitney and I'm
so glad you're talking about this
because here's the thing the micro
trauma and I know what I sound like
right now like I know that I fully sound
like myself and like whatever but like
that's where the human being is formed
and then we wonder why like the
trajectory is you know trash for the
rest it's like if you don't acknowledge
like the traumas that people expect I
was joking about like coming through
your mother's cervix it's a 10
I was doing this like deep EMDR stuff
with like trauma sexual abuse stuff like
that and then the MDR special is like
all right so at some point we should
deal with uh your Trauma from being
delivered from birth and I was like I
need
a break I was like I just can't this
might not take this on right because
whether it was a difficult birth whether
your mother was shot because the
epigenetic impact the genetic it's the
whole thing man and then by the there's
no air conditioning the dad wasn't that
whatever whatever going on in that room
and then in most hospitals around
whatever she was going through for nine
months that you were in there I mean
it's all past we if we took trauma
seriously like you know there's that
Aces score thing I don't know if you're
familiar with this but it's um adverse
childhood experiences is what Ace stands
for so basically there's a scale that
like pediatricians are starting to look
at it basically predicts what your life
will look like depending on the traumas
that you've experienced and it's so
clear and they're all preventable and
great news a lot of your traumas you've
blacked out 100 you don't remember good
luck with that right it's buried it's
down there I'm inviting you to come see
a movie that will help you unearth some
of these troubles though I was just like
this is the dream it's like to me this
is my favorite shit you're just in
Atlanta you're in the fucking get in
there like quicksand of just like honey
but this is it this is it to get your
house Matsu and get in there I'm willing
to be the person that it's like when I
froze my eggs like no one talked about
like it was like uncomfortable because
it's also expensive and I felt
privileged and I feel ashamed you know
it must be not and then well you're not
gonna and then I just start talking and
then Pete it just makes it normal right
the boy circumcision I know a lot of
women of friends of mine they're having
kids that are like what do I do about
and they do it in the hospital by the
way so it's not just about religion or
culture or whatever again larger
conversations how often we are a
fear-based culture that won't look at
the truth and we just sort of go I can't
hear you again and then we you know what
I mean I don't think you need to bring a
machine gun into a school unless
something happened to you in the first
couple years of your life it is we need
to figure figure out right what what
that is what that was also I don't think
you become a politician who ignores the
reality that you are propping up gun
companies that are killing your own
people like here's the thing I don't I'm
not saying I'm not trying to be a parody
of myself yeah I'm trying to look at the
reality that might that's just how you
think well my ex-husband's family came
over here on the Mayflower and they're
still racking up cash from way way back
then yet we don't you know rectify the
books when it comes to other things I'm
just saying if you're going to apply a
standard apply it evenly and if you're
going to see a movie see sell by date
you like that you like that little segue
but I re I'm I'm serious I'm excited
because the movie comes out in October
so we're like moments away and people
can see it in theaters in it here in L.A
and in New York starting to do like a
big event
come come come on yes I'll come to you
yeah yeah because I don't know I try to
just hear yeah oh honey you don't have
to say during the pandemic I know I
remember I was invited to something I
couldn't come I was so sad can I tell
you something else let's do it promotion
like I am so at a point the more posters
I see for something the more suspicious
I am of them you're only gonna see like
two posters for us we're Indie as fuck
we we got back to Word of Mouth this is
a word of mouth I'll only watch
something if the person someone I
respect hi I'm texting you my movie no
but that's no but I just mean in general
going like you have to see sell by date
it's the most but if I see like a giant
poster for something like why are you
trying so hard okay and also it's a
machine so like we're trying to get back
to like these conversations less machine
machines are great when they help the
fucking truth come out yeah so I'm into
it let's do it girl I'm here you know
listen oh I must I I would just like to
say I plan to um yeah I mean like the
long nobody pulls me over in the
neighborhood I'll be good sometimes the
key to a guy who's had trauma with women
I'm like just get a platonic girlfriend
it's but that's fucking true I know
that's crazy to say it's true to see a
human being across from you instead of a
conquest because a lot of our a lot of
the men that we live uh cohabit share
the world with my mom might not have
been available that's they had to drink
to survive that General saying the pills
were required it's the first generation
how sober moms okay
all the time
and then um oh God there's so much more
to say so much forever I am yeah let's
just do this again and again and again
because this conversation is never going
to be over and oh my god um I love
seeing a lot of glazer pops up in the
movie Brian Cranston pops up in the
movies very powerful
um very powerful scene
um and uh Rosario our our boo our shared
Boo the best tops up it's it's I can't
wait for people to see it and I'm ready
to learn uh please say your IG again yes
so you can find me on IG and all the
platforms at yes I'm Sarah Jones it's
all one word
y-e-s-i-m-s-a-r-a-h j o n e s with an H
because I'm a nice Jewish girl 10 the
best the best and these very awkwardly
um and I love you guys don't ride
elephants
[Music]